I was reading Dr. Bacola's email and he mentioned that a good way to measure stored estrogen in fat and tissues is through a prolactin lab.
And it should measure less than 10 nanograms per milliliter.
Would this be a good idea to monitor this number in between Dutch tests?
I don't know. I'll have to look at that research. I'm not familiar with that.
So that might be a great way to do it. I don't really know.
Second, I was wondered if my odd estrogen levels for my last Dutch test could be from the fact that I'm approaching 50 in menopause.
I've on said she was 62 so it may run late.
I was your mom didn't go through menopause until she was 62. Holy cats. That is late.
I was reading something that said horrible levels could be erratic during perimenopause. That's your absolutely right.
So to answer this question, yes, it could be very odd because of that so it could.
Perimenopause is good control your hormones into a tizzy.
That plus the fact that I had been on horrible blockers for six months. Yes, so could very well be.